un motivo de preocupación para los
líderes de la unión europea y justo
cuando se reanudan las conversaciones
sobre el break shit el ministro
británico para irlanda del norte de
brandon lewis ha respondido preguntas
sobre la nueva legislación gubernamental
que podría alterar partes del acuerdo de
la retirada del reino unido- con el
bloque el artículo 4 del protocolo de
irlanda del norte- establece los
lineamientos que especifican como la
zona seguirá siendo parte del territorio
aduanero del reino unido después del
berec si el gobierno dice que la nueva
legislación tiene como objetivo aclarar
como el acuerdo de retirada con la unión
europea se implementará pero admitió que
viola el derecho internacional con
respecto a belfast
si esto infringe la ley internacional de
una manera muy específica y limitada
estamos tomando el poder para no aplicar
el efecto directo de la ley de la unión
europea' requerido por el artículo 4 en
ciertas circunstancias muy estrictamente
definidas hay precedentes claros para
reino unido y de hecho otros países
necesitan considerar sus obligaciones
internacionales a medida que cambian las
circunstancias
lewis se insistió en que el reino unido
tenía la plena intención de implementar
el protocolo sobre irlanda del norte que
seguiría ejerciendo ciertas normas de la
unión europea para mantener abierta su
frontera terrestre con la república de
irlanda este martes cuando se produjeron
estas tensiones políticas un 6º
funcionario anunció su renuncia también
hablando en la cámara de los comunes la
ex primera ministra teresa me advirtió
que el proyecto de ley podría dañar la
confianza en el reino unido- sobre
futuros acuerdos comerciales con otros
estados